they're desperately trying to stop the
fires from spreading by burning ahead of
them to create a scar barrier which they
hope will stop it in its tracks often
this has been done too late to be very
effective the weather's been kinder
temperatures have dropped substantially
down 20 degrees in places and the first
rain drizzle in weeks has helped but
there are still far too many fires to
cope with more than a hundred and forty
are still burning in New South Wales
alone with 65 of them not contained
these scenes of fire crews battling on
the front lines have prompted a massive
fundraising effort as exhausted
volunteer crews work day and night
the Australian comedian Celeste barber
who has family in New South Wales has
helped to raise more than 20 million
dollars in just 48 hours for the
firefighters here many have sacrificed a
lot
we were told of at least one firefighter
who was unable to save his own home
because he was out battling to save
others
the Muskegon high house his car got
burned it is the gauge station all his
work tools in the back of his truck like
he's a builder a tradesman they lost the
lights but he's been on a fire truck
every day except today's demonstrated
feeling so he's been working non-stop
so you lost your house she got my [ __ ]
the car you got nothing left
and you're giving it to it helping the
community by doing the celebrity
donations to the fire crews come amid
ever mounting criticism of the
Australian Prime Minister especially
after his initial reluctance to give
compensation to these volunteers who are
still in the middle of this crisis all
the crews in this area are just hurting
they're tired where we're running
between many jobs
triple-a calls coming in from all
directions that we're trying to assist
and then seeing in our downtime we don't
get to rest we have to clean trucks
maintain them and get them prepared for
the next on sort once once you have
become a part of the RFS family you just
know it's a job that you have to do you
just you just put you your body on the
line and you work work your butt off to
community
fires have ripped through more than half
a dozen communities around Batemans Bay
in the past 12 hours destroying hundreds
of homes the fire swept through at such
a ferocious rate it took many people by
surprise they had about ten minutes to
get out of this Kevin Colebrook threw
buckets of water over himself to survive
and is furious at what he sees as the
government inaction and indifference the
out of this country because he did he
don't deserve to live in this country
anymore because he said everyone in
Australia's been let down by him that's
all they are
they're only lying in their own pockets
they don't care about us thousands are
without electricity or communications
after the fire brought down power lines
along the southeast coast were the
firefighters handing out tough words for
the country's politicians I think the
politicians have filed but they haven't
necessarily filed now I've been filing
for years and we need resources you know
where we we go out there with dodgy
radios we go it's really tough and hard
and they're really they're very good at
speaking but they're not very good in
their actions and they need to look
they're going they need to understand
the strategies changing the nature of
the fires has changing so we really need
some action from them not words but some
action they need to build our resources
for the future because it's not going to
get any better
let's go they actually get worse the
crisis is far from over yet but the
firefighters hoping the cooler damper
weather will hold long enough to make a
significant difference
Alex Crawford Sky News in New South
Wales Australia